and i just started having all of these
really negative thoughts about myself
lizzo is getting candid about sometimes
not feeling good as hell
oh my god in a series of videos posted
to tick-tock the singer opened up about
the struggles she often faces with her
body
image i came home i took my clothes off
to take a shower and i just started
having all of these really
negative thoughts about myself like you
know
what's wrong with me maybe everything
all the mean things people say about me
are true
and you know why am i so disgusting and
hating my body and um
normally i would have some positive
thing to say
to get me out of this but i don't she
went on to say that these thoughts are
normal and they happen to everybody and
i just have to know that
tomorrow how i feel in here is gonna
change
and i can only hope that it changes for
the better but i know i'm beautiful
i just don't feel it but i know i'm
gonna get through it shortly after
posting that video
lizzo seemingly bounced back showing off
her figure in
another tick tock writing in the caption
quote woke up
feeling better not one hundred percent
but i'm getting there
gave the parts of me i hated last night
a rub and a hug
nero mirror on the wall don't say
this isn't the first time the singer has
been candid about her appearance
back in june lizzo also took to
tick-tock to call out body shamers
hey so i've been working out
consistently for the last
five years and it may come as a surprise
to some of y'all
that i'm not working out to have your
ideal body type
i'm working out to have my ideal body
type
and you know what type that is none of
your
business because i am beautiful i am
strong
i do my job and i stay on my job
lizzo also told et in 2019 that
self-care is one of the many things
she's working on i want to feel good
like i um
when i was younger i had a friend who
was always helping me out with self-care
and he would be like
you know you got to take some time to
meditate and you got to eat bagels with
cream cheese and you got to chill
and i was like you're so good at this
you're so good at being happy and he was
like
well i'm only good at being happy
because i was so sad i need it the most
and
you know it's the same with me like i
need this music to be my therapy
because i have been so low and i refuse
to
you know live life like that anymore